it'll be the end of tesla y if it goes  through i just think that they're going  to do everything they can in terms of  government contracts regulations support  it could affect his space ender's risers  because a lot of his the whole world has  been okay so that will between  government and private that's exactly  why  taking money from the government is the  is not a freaking good move because they  eventually  strong army like like he's talking about  did you get that spacex would you take  money  they'll eventually say if you do this  here's what we're gonna do because we  fed you this that's exactly why the  nationalized system doesn't work exactly  that's exactly why that doesn't work